[music]
you fled to your son in Mariupol and then
sat and nine-story buildings and threw bombs at
us,
then already changed three shelters and Mariupol
USA worked there and in general the bombs were thrown
scary
Mariupol was magical a little
bombed and you didn’t even expect Shipuden
such an attack no one  waited no one
expected it was such a pit to
tell whether it’s all that can be flown through the
house past people for weeks didn’t get out
from under the wave for weeks as they cooked
everything was cooked on the first floor while
getting into the house was direct we didn’t have
our apartment there well  to fill in the second entrance to the
apartment
, and hits were dropped in this air regiment
around the yard, the top went in strikes, they
just held
together with us, too, people seemed to
rally, of course, the land rallies
people and also sabato the rock branches and
shot and all this rock the corpses piled up
there to bought or wounded  they all
piled up the
building there nearby they buried it on
playgrounds, yes, I buried a person in the yard
, but we also plunged, I
quickly here 10 people micro  I
wanted a chair for nine with a driver, they
stared at a chair because it was necessary to
take out people's legs top asked then they
took us out, but while the tour was already our driver,
we then only for 2 days we realized
that we were not driving along the corridor, they could
simply shoot us about
threatened  we said we can throw it away
and take the car to the army and you
just shoot the
furniture to yourself
there is nothing they say everyone marvel I press
we take it
caught fire
I haven’t been
to
many
didn’t become everything that was
understandable
who
is where but
hardly anyone along the way
well